the emails are coming back to by las
vegas raiders coach john gruden forcing
him to call it quits according to
reports the emails came to light during
a toxic workplace investigation into the
washington football team the skins some
of those emails were sent over a decade
ago from his personal email account
while gruden worked for espn
according to the original report by the
journal one of his emails dated july 21
2011 said this
the brosis smith has lips the size of
michelin tires smith is black
reporting by the new york times reveals
more dicey messages sent by gruden quote
in the emails gruden called the league's
commissioner roger goodell an f word and
a clueless anti-football p
and said that goodell should not have
pressured jeff fisher than the coach of
the rams to draft queers a reference to
michael sam a gay player chosen by the
team in 2014.
so there's a debate now in the country
should john gruden have been fired join
me now with their takes fox and friend
weekend co-host will kane and fox news
contributor richard fowler i just said
just to begin obviously
he said something really bad against the
commissioner the commissioner then
leaked it to the times to get him fired
and you know you mess with the
commissioner like that that's what
happens so richard fowler put that aside
for a second
should
gruden
have been asked for this
listen i think i'm happy to see he
resigned so he wasn't like actually
fired even though we're not sure how
that went down but i think he should
have been not only were these email
these emails heinous but beyond that
they sort of speak to the opposite of
who the raiders franchise tried to be
the raiders locker room but the raiders
franchise is known for being a
trailblazer in diversity and inclusion
and what makes these emails even more
upsetting is that he sent them to nfl
presidents right and nfl team owners and
other nfl coaching staff so maybe gruden
is more emblematic of what the nfl
leadership looks like
than anything else well i mean it is uh
it's football you know people think it's
a private situation i don't know will
kane i mean it was some bad stuff in
there do you think he should have kept
his job
well let me first submit to exactly what
you and richard said i mean these were
vulgar and and shameful statements that
john gruden made but to answer your
question directly jesse should he have
gotten fired then i have to ask what's
the standard for somebody getting fired
because all i can ascertain in 2021 is
you're fired when the mob requires that
you're fired and we are increasingly
enacting executions in mob justice with
greater speed and greater punishment
this happened 10 years ago to your point
some of them 2011. they were all by
previous employment none of them while
he was with the raiders so he's going to
pay the price with his current job for
what he did in his past job
what more and this is and this is uh i
think this is important jesse i don't
think anybody is truly truly outraged
look anybody in this locker room not
only have they heard worse they've said
worse i think most people have covered
sports have heard worse and said worse i
think the people in the executive
offices of the nfl and park avenue have
heard worse and said as bad that's not
to excuse john gruden at all but i want
to know who is the morally pure to keep
casting all these executions to keep
firing people i want to know what the
standard is if we're also morally pure
it's not a merely
pure league richard you think you have
players in there some of them you know
put knives in people some of them are
wife beaters some of them are child
abusers
there's been some real rough stuff that
have been people have been given second
chances in the nfl because they have
talent do you see any sort of hypocrisy
there
well listen i think there should be
accountability and transparency across
the board but it's worth pointing out
that not only were some of these emails
from 2011 but there were some from 2018
right so if you are a coach of a team
you're supposed to be the leader you're
supposed to be the leader the one that
sets the bar both in your locker room as
well as on the field how do you have the
ability and the authority to do that if
you're sending emails that are racist
emails that are homophobic emails that
are downright degrading to people who
work work for you well yeah this is not
everyone's email speaks
a problem with the lead you take
everyone's private email from many many
years ago richard there's obviously
going to be trouble but to his point
will
i if he comes out and says you know what
i've changed or i apologize do you think
he can still lead an nfl team do you
think these guys are going to be
offended by some of these comments or
they're going to be like okay let's go
let's go win on something i think some
will i think some will be offended and i
think ultimately he probably could have
held that locker room and he had the
raiders off to a great start this year
that's beside the point i guess of how
well he coaches or how well they were
doing you know really quickly
richard said we need accountability mike
my condition is we're not looking for
accountability we're looking for power
and that's why desean watson today
although he's not he's suspended is
still in the nfl all right and john
gruden is not we're not looking for
accountability no we're looking for
scapegoats and reporting across the
commissioner
you're toast we gotta run raymond is up
next on the clock hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else